meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
schönen guten tag die lage ist sehr sehr
ernst und wird jeden tag schwieriger wir
haben ein exponentielles wachstum in
bayern jetzt heute den höchsten stand
den wir von allen welten in der
infektion über 13.000 insgesamt 90.000
krank der menschen in unserem land wir
liegen derzeit mit einer insgesamt
instanz um 250 auf platz drei war es
sachsen und thüringen hat mehr biss
zieht durchs ganze land und es zieht
auch durch ganz deutschland
die entwicklung zu glauben dass
beschränke sich auf ein paar hotspots
und erreiche nicht ganz deutschland ist
aus unserer sicht eine illusion ganz im
gegenteil es entwickelt sich weiter und
wir sehen auch an anderen länder
nachbarländern holland und dänemark dass
die situation dort auch wieder
schlechter die gründe sind relativ klar
auf der hand es gibt drei hauptgründe
das eine ist und davon gebe es aus von
denen die nicht geimpft sind wir hatten
am anfang die höchsten infektionszahlen
hotspots dort wo auch die niedrigste
impfquote sind das sind bleibt das
grundproblem ungeimpft bedeutet
schutzlos zweitens die impf durchbrüche
nehmen zu und
zwar in verstärktem umfang das ist
vergleichbar gewesen jetzt in israel vor
einigen wochen hatten eine relativ
starkes zu wachsen und es ist nicht nur
so dass es milde verläufe gibt sondern
bei denen die älteren vorher schon
schwer kranken so wurde das war doch
berichtet wächst es auch zunehmend jetzt
in eine schwere krankheitsverläufe
hinein das heißt das thema impft
durchbruch und bahnbrücke impfung ich
komme gleich dazu ist ganz zentral und
ist drittel wir haben weniger
bereitschaft auch der menschen die lage
wirklich so zu sehen wie sie sehr ernst
und viele tun sich schwer an die regeln
zu halten und das ganze
ergänzt sich dann auch dadurch dank sehr
dass wir doch die pflege dabei ist dass
wir insgesamt einen
stillen rückzug einiger aus der pflege
haben einfach weil sie nicht nur
demotiviert sind durch das verhalten
mancher ungeimpfte soll an der
gesamtsituation der rahmenbedingungen
einfach nicht dieses erfüllt wurde was
man über all die zeit erhofft gesprochen
hat deswegen haben wir uns heute noch
mal unterhalten mit den klinikchefs
praktisch aus ganz bayern und den
pflegeleiterin den pflegekräften vielen
dank dafür mit einem relativ
einheitlichen bild des sehr fachlich
aber zum teil auch sehr emotional war
fakt ist die krankenhäuser sind voll
sie haben das glaube ich sagt maximal am
limit sowohl von der belastung als auch
von der
emotionalen situation und deswegen ist
es wichtig dass wir jetzt erklären wir
haben tatsächlich nicht nur die suche
nach einem bett für ungeimpfte sondern
wir bekommen eine zusätzliche situation
dass all diejenigen die geimpft sind und
nicht wegen kobelt ins krankenhaus
müssen probleme bekommen ihren platz zu
finden und intensiv dies kann auf dauer
so nicht sein deswegen haben wir gestern
gemeinsam entschieden im k fall
auszurufen während der bund epidemische
lage beendet rufen wir den k fall aus
wobei der k fall nicht psychologische
gründe hat wobei das auch dazu kommt
weil es allen noch einmal verdeutlicht
wie ernst die lage ist diente vor allem
der patienten steuerung der effizienten
schnellen betten management und auch der
möglichkeit freie betten zu organisieren
alle klinik mit einzuziehen und
einzubeziehen in dem prozess pflege puls
zu reaktivieren von freiwilligen pflegen
kräften die sich da gemeldet hatten auch
der reaktivierung von ehemaligen
pflegekräften sozusagen die
generalmobilmachung in der pflege an der
stelle auszurufen dies geht nur mit dem
k verdanke ich auch dem innenminister
der das formalität her so vollzogen hat
das wurde heute auch von den krankenhaus
klinikchefs den pflegern als positiv
gewertet
ich glaube aber nicht dass das reicht
die debatte im bundestag habe das was
der bund jetzt macht reicht nicht
olaf scholz hat heute gesagt man müsse
jetzt gut über den winter kommen und
dann müsse deutschland winterfest machen
man kann bei einem stürmischen winter
nicht mit sommerreifen fahren das
bisherige angebot ist er ein
sommerreifen cet statt ein winterpaket
das wird nicht funktionieren entspricht
zwar keiner mehr auch der betroffenen
ampel partner von freedom daher aber das
war die ankündigung beendet epidemischen
lage mit der ankündigung beides fliehen
dies ist absurd ich freue mich sehr dass
nächste woche eine mpk jetzt stattfindet
aber was haben wir für einen druck
entfachen müssen dass wir überhaupt
reden können ich finde den zeitpunkt
deswegen nach unten nicht optimal er
hätte vor diesen gesetzesvorschlag sein
müssen und nicht quasi wenn das
gesetzgebungsverfahren abgeschlossen und
vorbei ist denn es gibt eine menge zu
besprechen was fehlt wir brauchen zweig
flächendeckend in deutschland und zwar
wo es nur geht ich werde auch in bayern
vorschlagen unseren koalitionspartner
hier an der stelle noch einmal
grundlegend das zur weiter 2 gewo
möglich ist und dann auch wenn zwei gs
die maske zu verwenden einfach deswegen
zum schutz also bis zu den jeweiligen
platz wenn abstand gewahrt lässt auch
zweig mit maske zu machen und wir werden
vorschlagen dass man in den bereichen wo
wir auch die situation dass man quasi
überhaupt nicht ausweichen kann clubs
und discos auf zweig plus umzusteigen
das wäre der vorschlag zweige plus heißt
dass dort ein schnelltest noch einmal
gemacht wird bevor man in das vergnügen
startet das wichtigste ist um die
akzeptanz von impfungen und von 2 gegen
und zu halten muss auch die maximale
sicherheit an der stelle gewährleistet
werden also für deutschland zweig soweit
irgend wie möglich umsetzen
3g am arbeitsplatz das ist in den
vorlagen nicht drin muss konsequent
umgesetzt werden muss auch mit dem
auskunftsrecht und der möglichkeit zu
erkennen wer beispielsweise geimpft ist
oder nicht es fehlt auf bundesebene der
krankenhaus ausgleich wir empfinden es
als eine echte schwachstelle die
krankenhäuser brauchen ausgleich
szenarien wir haben in bayern wir
entschieden schon den kurve zuschlag zu
geben der kombi zuschlag ist ein erster
ansatz den wir gemacht haben sozusagen
ein motivationsschub der zur hälfte als
aus geht zur hälfte an die pflegekräfte
ausbezahlt werden soll wir brauchen
jetzt aber dazu mehr wir brauchen eine
grundlegende kostenübernahme durch den
bund bei dem freihalten von betten und
dazu brauchen wir auch bei allen
zuschlägen wie es gibt und wir brauchen
noch mehr an zuschlägen für die
pflegekräfte müssen die dann auch
steuerfrei sein so dass ein zuschlag
nicht im grunde genommen durch das
steuerrecht verpufft sondern muss dort
ankommen wo es hin kommt nämlich ein
motivationsschub an der stelle zu sein
hinzu wird bayern wir haben das jetzt
gemeinsam auf vorschlag des
gesundheitsministers macht werden wir
noch eine frei halte pauschale für uns
machen von 300 euro pro bett das auch
insgesamt betten frei gehalten werden in
der abrechnung und das alle
krankenhäuser mit einbezogen werden
können also dass nicht nur die ab
verlegung klappt die im zu gewinnung und
steuerung des personals sondern eben
auch der bereich der krankenhäuser
gestärkt werden diese bereiche fehlen
aber auf bundesebene
ebenso viel zu einer klaren
übereinstimmung wie wir mit dem impfen
umgehen soll wir brauchen eine
impfpflicht für bestimmte berufsgruppen
das ist meinung nach notwendig wir
brauchen ein klares commitment der
länder und des bundes nicht die stiko
empfehlung zur basis zu nehmen stiko
empfehlung heißt erst ab 70 dies ist
sorry wenn ich dir sage einfach zu spät
und der lage nicht angemessen
ich respektiere die stiko nicht dass wir
erneut es kommt aber wir müssen uns da
anders orientieren wir müssen jetzt als
einzige echte chance die wir haben und
die uns bleibt ist vor allem impfen
impfen impfen deswegen ist wichtig die
dritte impfung voranzubringen aus meiner
sicht in israel wird es ab dem fünften
monat gemacht mit mittlerweile großen
erfolgen man kann nur empfehlen so
schnell wie möglich zu machen parallel
die impfzentren die wir ja reaktivieren
jetzt auch hoch zu fahren so schnell wie
möglich durch die kommunen und ich werde
das als positives signal meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren wenn es jetzt
wieder schlangen vor den impfzentren
gibt es ist sehr gut genauso positiv
werde ich jetzt auch wenn der eine
andere sich noch mal überzeugend hat
lassen doch zu impfen ich finde es ein
gutes signal dass jetzt das ganze
kabinett geimpft ist mein ausdrücklicher
dank und ich finde das kann vielleicht
auch eine an einem signal oder hilfs
wirkung seien für viele die noch
skeptisch sind ich appelliere an dringen
dass es im fußball genauso ist wenn ich
für das keine überzeugende situation
wenn zweig für die zuschauer gilt aber
die spieler sich nicht daran halten da
denke ich um die einheit von fans und
fußball gut zu organisieren werde es
noch meine kollegin auch hansi flick da
sehr sehr dankbar der das noch mal
gesagt hat und zwar wie ich finde sowohl
stil inhalt aber auch von der
zielrichtung für mehr als angemessen
hinzu kommt auch das müssen wir dann
gesagt auf der bundesebene klären dass
wir die einheitliche empfehlung haben
eben für nicht an 70 uns orientieren
schneller heran zu gehen auch von der
zeitachse möglicherweise schon ab dem
fünften monat dies zu entscheiden ich
glaube das wäre ganz wichtig hinzu kommt
das müssen wir natürlich machen die
kontrollen zu erhöhen damit das ganze
funktioniert es wird eine zentrale frage
sein was auch fehlt ist auf bundesebene
irgendeine notfall optionen wir haben
keine einzige notfall aktion
am ende bleibt es bei a ha
zweig das war's dann es gibt keine
möglichkeit mehr wieder über kontakte zu
reden noch über veranstaltungen zu reden
dies ist nicht mehr möglich danach der
neuen bundesrecht
dies ist die eigentliche achillesferse
also es wird überhaupt keine möglichkeit
geben egal wie die infektions lage ist
heißt dieses neue gesetz augen zu und
durch dies glaube ich ist unangemessen
für die situation in den krankenhäusern
und den menschen gegenüber da braucht es
etwas mehr das sind müssen wir zum
beispiel auch darüber reden wie wir mit
veranstaltungen um die nächste woche bei
der mpk zb die weihnachtsmärkte nach dem
gesetz gibt es keine möglichkeit darüber
zu reden das meiner ansicht ist das
mindeste ist mindeste maske ist das
mindeste was man da machen kann aber es
gibt weder zum alkohol noch andere
rechtliche möglichkeit nach
infektionsschutzgesetz dies zu verändern
das heißt nicht dass weihnachtsmarkt
stattfinden könnten theoretisch und wir
brauchen eine einheitliche regelung in
deutschland und jetzt gibt es einzelne
kommunen wo ich sehr respektiere dass
ihre entscheidungen treffen sowie dem
oktoberfest auch der fall ist aber wir
bräuchten eine einheitliche regelung
genau so und das respektiere ich sehr
ich mich aber noch ein bisschen schwer
mit den karneval jetzt in den nächsten
wochen sofort zu stellen ohne maske und
schunkeln auch da tu ich mich schwer
vielleicht müssen wir auch darüber reden
wie das ganze stattfindet ohne dem einer
kollegin da jetzt irgend eine vorgabe
machen das sind dinge die müssen in
einer mpk einfach gesprochen werden und
so nicht quasi wenn das ganze schon
vorbei sondern erst wenn es losgeht
wir haben jetzt heute eben noch einmal
besprochen neben dem café unsere
maßnahmen zu treffen was das
reaktivieren von pflegepersonal betrifft
ich habe schon angesprochen und das
einzelne maßnahmen gibt die wird in der
koalition auch beraten wollen und werden
ich glaube insgesamt dass die situation
deswegen ernst ist und deswegen können
wir jetzt auch keine kompromisse machen
wir müssen versuchen an der stelle so
viel und so klare regeln wie möglich zu
haben den menschen noch einmal zu
verdeutlichen wie ernst die lage ist
dringend für das impfen zu werden ohne
impfen ende das alles in irgendeiner
form von
schwierigkeit ist muss man einfach stift
einfach nichts es ist nicht weil wir
jetzt alle im fans per se sind aber wir
wir glauben fest daran dass ist eine der
wenigen möglichkeiten ist man sieht
übrigens an israel durch das durch die
booster impfung ist doch noch mal eine
ziemliche entlastung gegeben hat so dass
wir dann immer zwei dinge erreichen
können alt von schule
gehalt auch von so viel normalität wie
möglich ist unser klares ziel wir wollen
kein lockt aber wir wollen auch nichts
zu spüren aber deswegen im meer zweig
oder zweige plus zu machen und am ende
zählt nur eines nämlich der schutz von
land und leute dass das entscheide und
umgekehrt eben dazu dass die normale
gesundheitsversorgung funktioniert das
ist schon mal zentral dass leute nicht
abgewiesen werden dass leute nicht
ehrlich gesagt eine ganze nacht
herumgefahren werden müssen um einen
normalen herz kreislauf erkrankung
überhaupt ein bett zu bekommen und dass
pflegekräfte nicht den eindruck haben es
wird alles nur für im rücken ausgetragen
ich hab grundlegendes verständnis dass
man für höhere löhne wird das sage ich
ausdrücklich
vielleicht kann man überlegen ob der
streik der beispielsweise von berlin
kommt es kann natürlich im rahmen
möglichkeit okay aber ob jetzt in dem
fall den kliniken sein muss noch einmal
überlegen geht es nicht an sie sondern
es geht an alle in der stadtplanung
würde jetzt eine verdeckte woche denn
das könnte schon noch mal zu
unangenehmen situation
führen können und das wollen wir alle
nicht
fazit vielen dank für das gespräch
danke für die tolle leistung die sie im
pflege und medizin machen das muss man
ehrlich sagen und wir müssen jetzt einen
engen schulterschluss und einen
gemeinsamen ruck nach vorne bringen um
diese schwierige situation zu bewältigen
es ist kein hexenwerk dagegen vorzugehen
nur sich der situation zu verweigern
führt nicht zur lösung wird eher
schlechter und deswegen muss man jetzt
auch einsteigen vielen dank
vielen dank herr staatsminister politik
mitte wir haben eine sehr geehrten damen
und herren ich glaube es war wichtig
aus dieser pressekonferenz in münchen
und mit der großen frage fahren wir mit
sommerreifen in diesen corona winter
oder rüsten will schon schneeketten auf
obwohl es nur regennasse straßen sind
zwei männer zwei meinungen olaf scholz
und jetzt eben gerade markus söder und
auch hier im studio werden wir jetzt
darüber diskutieren wenn man's
verstärkungen geholt für die pid auf bei
uns chef unseres meinungs- ressorts
findet falls wir uns einmal zusammen was
markus söder dort seinen corona planen
präsentierte sind das für dich geeignete
winterreifen oder erzeugen wir die autos
mit schneeketten auf obwohl die straßen
vielleicht auch anderes zu ließen würden
ja das ist ein klassischer markus söder
arbeitet hervorragend mit sprachbildern
heute morgen erklärt olaf scholz er will
deutschland winterfest machen jetzt
schlägt markus söder zurück und erklärt
tja wir fahren erwerben aber
sommerreifen und mit sommerreifen kommt
man nicht durch den winter aber das ist
natürlich das sind alles nur metaphern
worum geht es wirklich er sagt der ampel
plan reicht nicht aus wir können jetzt
nicht die epidemische lage verlassen wir
können jetzt nicht locker uns
ausschließen kontakt beschränkung
ausgangssperren ausschließen sondern
erfordert eine sogenannte notfall option
das heißt die ampel muss nachschärfen
scholz muss nach schaffen das ist die
große forderung von markus söder man
muss an einem punkt sagen er will dass
man sofort flächendeckend in ganz
deutschland zweig entführt und da muss
man sich schon mal fragen was hat markus
söder in bayern denn davon wenn in
schleswig-holstein und bremen jetzt
zweig eingeführt wird das ist eine
politische nebelkerze eine nebelkerze
wie markus söder sie schon ganz oft
geschmissen hat in die in den mp cars
und insgesamt in seiner corona politik
ihm geht es darum dass das ganze land
mit zieht er geht voran und die menschen
in bayern fragen sich nicht warum sind
unsere regeln eigentlich strenger als
die in norddeutschland aber natürlich
wollen die norddeutschen jetzt nicht in
den chor ohne notfall modus schalten nur
weil markus söder seine zahlen nicht im
griff hat also das ist ein politischer
streit mal wieder um die deutungshoheit
um die regel hoheit in sachen corona
jetzt im moment verläuft der streit
zwischen der ampel und zwischen
ministerpräsidenten wie vor allen dingen
bayerns ministerpräsident markus söder
also so dagegen scholz lässt sich das
kurz auf den punkt bringen und da geht
es eben auch um ganz wichtigen termin
nächste woche
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am nächsten
donnerstag also in genau einer woche die
hat scholz heute im bundestag
angekündigt untersagt söder heute das
kann nicht sein dass wir da nur noch
beschließen was schon beschlossen ist
sondern wir müssen noch mal richtig an
an der schraube drehen können wir müssen
nachschärfen den ampel planen richtig
dass diese mpk wird wirklich eine krone
eskalation bedeuten und wird auch
wirklich eine herausforderung für unsere
demokratie weil wir eigentlich gerade
eine neue dabei sind eine neue regierung
zu beobachten die jetzt ihr
gesetzgebungs paket ihr corona paket für
den winter vorgelegt hat dass es die
bundestagsmehrheit diese menschen die
haben wir gewählt und jetzt kommt doch
noch mal die mpk also das format dieser
corona gipfel aus dem kanzleramt und den
bundesländern dass wir eigentlich nicht
mehr da haben wollten weil die für so
viel chaos gesorgt hatten und die wollen
sich jetzt gegen die bundestags mehrheit
gegen die ampel positionieren also die
alte bundesregierung jetzt nur noch
geschäftsführend im amt ist mit
bundeskanzlerin merkel kanzleramtschef
braun die will etwas neues bewirken was
die ampel eigentlich verhindern will
also die mpk wird vermutlich versuchen
ein zeichen auch eventuell für eine neue
lok tor zu setzen oder zumindest für
eine lockt option die markus ohne esel
jetzt angesprochen hat werden die ampel
genau das verhindern will letzte ganz
kurze antwort weil es um so viel
alltagsfragen aktuell geht was bedeutet
dass wenn wir alle jetzt wieder sorge
oder angst vor dem neuen locker und
haben beispielsweise weihnachtsmärkte
heute hören wir auf sagt aus sachsen von
ministerpräsident beck mit den
weihnachtsmärkten er ist für die absage
aller weihnachtsmärkte in sachsen söder
hat sich dazu auch gerade geäußert also
finden die jetzt statt in deutschland ja
oder nein die buden sind aufgebaut es
ist eine wirklich spannende situation es
ist aber auch eine bizarre situation wir
sind im kompletten schwebezustand
niemand kann sagen welche corinna regeln
in zwei oder drei wochen oder auch nur
in einem monat oder an weihnachten
gelten werden wir haben eine alte
regierung die will das eine ist aber
bald nicht mehr im amt wir haben eine
neue regierung die noch nicht im amt ist
und gerade sind alle auf
konfrontationskurs angeführt von scholz
und söder und nur einer kann sich
durchsetzen und wirklich wir wissen
nicht was sein wird wir wissen nicht was
fürs weihnachtsfest bedeutet wir wissen
nicht was das für weihnachtsmärkte
bedeutet wir wissen auch nicht was das
für den karneval jetzt bedeutet wir
wissen nicht mal was das für schulen
krankenhäuser bedeuten wird